bella gente riesce benissimo questo
nuovissimo video io sono felice oggi
siamo sul gas and glory che
effettivamente ho fatto l'ultimo
episodio spero vi sia piaciuto è un
gioco che non portava da un sacco di
tempo forse ho sbagliato a scegliere
personaggio prova bel salve e buongiorno
si faccia i cazzi suoi grazie
ecco questo che avremo zoe è una legge
preferite perché fa questo cieli con la
moto bolano una merda scherzava ma
teoricamente se non riuscissi a
lanciarli sul traguardo sarebbe anche
più facile se non è prodotti bella bella
non comprendo però come un attimo debba
devo andare sempre più su minchia
ragazzi sarà ma come è una prova troppo
difficile per me perché effettivamente
io non lo so fare con la moto mi hanno
insegnato a farlo quando ho fatto la
patente fosse normale tranquilla testata
fa bene bella bellissima ma nessuna
perdita di pepe ok ok mi le mine allora
questa parte è molto più semplice perché
a schivare ostacoli effettivamente nella
casa
allora io una volta queste cose le
tagliavo per non fiori ma è ora che
monta giampiero no alle taglierà e fa
bene fa bene vediamo come come realmente
succede nella vita le fa di questa
questa la mia vita da sembra che anche
che mario era così ok ok ma sì cosa vuoi
che sia ma cosa vuoi che simili atti
meno male che ce la sta freccia
meno male che ce la sta facendo utile
tra l'altro perché stavo domandare però
madonna ma salvato il culo doveva da don
da lì sopra va bene così e vabbè c'è
anche un traguardo ma come adobe aiuto
noda vabbè ma era atterrato bene ma cosa
ma posso andare anche i 40 dritto
vabbè vabbè se riesco a farlo così in
merito cioè mi merito un limone aspetta
salve buongiorno grande complimenti
poiché l'ho fatto cazzuto giorno è stato
a ballare sui tetti comunque nice
facciamo un compendio pedro e il toro
che sempre per la madonna gringos alto
ma dove va bè gringo un cazzo proprio ma
cos'è sta roba è il medico può più
toscano e messi che hanno comunque va
beh ok ok capito tutto spaccato ma fa
niente deve avere vabbè ma non è non è
così facile come sempre ai ragazzi
perché devo tenere difficile tenerla la
strada questa macchina ecco i file l'ho
detto e lo dico io quando parlo il suo
gioco
mi sto creando dei un futuro nefasto ok
non è possibile
ok a una normale fanno le fanno così le
macchine al giorno d'oggi siete voi che
non siete informati higher and higher
con martin geier st questo beach è camon
un saltino proprio qui non lo posso fare
però faccio che scavano le montagne
questa macchina che si può fare
che problema c'è madonna sono caduto su
un cannone non fa niente ciao
andiamo sempre con pedro perché vedrò
esprime da cos'è e vabbè un attimo
eccessivo zio mi sembra un attimo
eccessiva questi incazzatura una parte
tua
la ragazza aiuto c'erano spara qui che a
noi cioè fermi fermi
questo andazzo aiuto al micca non li
sulle macchine non sto male non ragazze
aiuto e corri corri quali c'è un
calcetto ma il giudice va bene vado
c'era un cancello a ma si sfonda si
sfonda però da vivo dopo sfondarlo resa
non mi contro cazzo volata un po di
gente ma fa niente musona ho preso una
palla di cannone nelle palle della
macchina che le palle come spiegare la
parte sotto la macchina come si chiama
le palle madonna madonna vado tra
governo e il traguardo
porca vacca che ho fatto una provata
dove traguardo 270 m 3 in chiedo a me lo
fa fare il biglietto lo so già io me lo
fa fare tutto indietro tutto salve buona
macchina va bene non fa niente va bene
la prossima volta prendo anche pago il
biglietto per vedere
ok meno male che ha fatto check point ma
allora allora allora allora lega da 19
ragazza aiuto ok 100 metri ci siamo
ragazzi non dico ci siamo perché c'è
ancora una macchina lo schivata ha
ucciso un tizio che non c'entrava niente
porro cristiano va bene ai de sica ma
non so bene e va bene non ci passa
allora non farlo gioco ditemelo voi e il
laser e mi tagliano i due vero b non li
devo prendere manco per sbaglio ok
vabbè minchiam e nuvole che dovrei solo
preso dal pregio lo prendo preso verrà
presto madonna meno male meno male per
male mela prezzo perché ero morto ho
fatto delle robe che non sa più spiega
tutto ok
qual è il mart player ma adesso giocato
quello che mal player camuffato da da da
da pablo escobar
ok bella molto bella bella a tutti i
ragazzi l'esca già fatto non ce l'ho
fatto anche fare sta roba incredibile
nuovo in fuga partiti quali sono museo
mart player anno hanno messo la ferita
il gioco ha un uomo in fuga giustamente
deve schivare le macchine in primis eco
lo vedo
pessimo pessimo pessimo pessimo non ho e
non ho più le ruote non ha le ruote sta
andando a caso non le ruote più duro
sono a noi non posso più sterzare fare
niente
vado così né per inerzia
oddio ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta e poi
il tempo andiamo con john il gaming
non ho sbagliato a schiacciare come fa
niente giorno ho sbagliato a schiacciare
devo prendere giovane jimmy madonna però
mica ragazzi a cipro dopo ci prova oggi
super pro tranqui tranqui morto e posso
cambiare personaggio con una cacca in
testa magari no
esatto questo questo volevo questo
volevo medi che andavo più forte prima
scommette no non male la cacca e faccio
anche il rustico la bici che figata
lei calma
ok calma sempre sempre più calma
tranquilli tranquilli
let's go perfetto nice nice nice so che
voleva bene non ci passano in mezzo
sappilo ci sono tessuti
non so come altra altra autostrada bella
zio bella zio bella che è sogno che sei
una donna belga era mai chi è lo stai
parlando a fare lì quindi ragazzuoli
spero che vi sia piaciuto questo era gas
cloro e 2 fateci sapere se volete un
terzo episodio quasi tornati subito vi
piace anche ai social news descrizione
c'è ne sono gli scheletri e noi come
sempre non troviamo il telecomando belle
ragazze
[Musica]